woke went broke that's the subject of
tonight's waters words here's what
happened to the democratic party this
week
[Music]
americans are fed up with the democrats
we won't stand by while liberals destroy
the country so give yourselves a round
of applause
[Applause]
here's what the red wave looks like
virginia went red just a year after
biden won by 10. a republican nearly
toppled the new jersey governor estate
biden won by 16.
a rare red wave hit long island too and
minneapolis voted against dismantling
the police department
the law and order candidate in seattle
remember chop or chaz whatever it was
called they beat the pants off the
radical left d.a there and right in
beat the socialist in buffalo
common sense had a very big week what
does this all mean
you see what happens in virginia
will in large part determine
what happens in 2022 2024 and on
wow so there's one thing kamala and i
agree on let's check in with her boss
we're going to win
i think we're going to win in virginia
like most things biden didn't see it
coming on the day of the reckoning a
reporter asked joe biden if he took any
responsibility for democrats getting
shellacked
joe said no the country is just confused
i just think people are at a point and
it's understandable
where there's a whole lot of confusion
we're not confused the american people
aren't stupid we know exactly what's
going on and we don't like it
biden's agenda isn't our agenda
we want lower prices cheaper gas
stronger borders but biden keeps serving
us vax mandates and places to plug in
our electric cars
we don't even drive electric cars
here was the key in virginia
the left started a critical race theory
culture war and they lost look what
terry mcauliffe ran on
i don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach
yunkan ran against racism in the
classroom he actually listened to
parents
but terry listened to the teachers union
and called parents racist domestic
terrorists
and after he lost most of the media
wouldn't even admit why critical race
theory is not taught in virginia schools
it's not a big deal critical race theory
which isn't real critical race theory
was a lie young jumped on board with the
wright's new freakout over something
called critical race theory a thing they
can't define and that isn't taught in
k-12 schools anyway
like an alcoholic they're in denial the
first step is admitting you guys have a
problem
the media can't do that here because crt
says whites are born racist whites are
still oppressing blacks and whites are
only successful because of white
supremacy
could you see rachel maddow look into
the camera and tell her audience she's a
racist
maddow would have to confess she got a
tv show because of white supremacy
she'd have to apologize to joy reid for
oppressing her
because that's the key to crt
it's garbage but the left-wing media
can't stand up to the far left so they
don't say crt doesn't exist
not only doesn't crt exist they say but
speaking out against something that
doesn't exist is racist
junkin played the race card for a reason
because he knows it works on certain
white voters racism raised his ugly head
and the republican candidate used it
very aptly some of it was
uh dog whistle racism
it was not a dog whistle it was a bull
horn
only a fool would say virginia rejecting
racism in schools is racist this is the
state that voted for barack obama twice
junkid won 55 percent of hispanic vote
60 percent of the white vote he doubled
donald trump's numbers with black
females
that's what the left calls a rainbow
coalition
the numbers don't lie but the media does
americans are sick and tired of the left
calling them racist calling their kids
racist calling the country racist
martin luther king would have opposed
critical race theory listen
because i have a dream
that my
four little children
will one day live in a nation where they
will not be judged by the color of their
skin but by the content of their
character
the left has turned mlk upside down he
wanted a colorblind society but all the
left wants to see his color
so-called racist virginia citizens
elected the first statewide black female
office holder
lieutenant governor elect winsome sears
listen
there are some who want to divide us and
we must not let that happen
they would like us to believe we are
back in 1963 we can live where we want
we can eat where we want we own the
water fountains here i am living proof
the american people are rejecting the
race card and democrats are scrambling
they don't have any other card to play
they can't play the trump card can't
play russia russia russia kovid's fading
and so now they have to run on the
issues and not surprisingly they're
getting clobbered some democrats are
trying to warn them you go woke you're
going to go broke
democrats are going to have to come face
to face with this issue of locus this is
stupid
just defund the police
lunacy just take abraham lincoln's name
off of schools i mean that
people see that some of these people
need to go to a woke detox center i
think that the democrats are coming
across in ways that we don't recognize
that are annoying
and offensive um and seem out of touch
in ways that i don't think show up in
our feeds when we're looking at our kind
of echo chamber
so the democratic party is at a
crossroads right now do they die on the
woke hill or retreat to fight another
day
we're seeing the same kind of split in
congress watch
it's a wake-up call for all of us i'm
concerned i've been talking about our
debt i've been talking about inflation
i've been talking about the fallout we
may have this is not a center left or a
left country
we are a center if anything has a little
center-right country i think that the
results show the limits of trying to run
a fully 100 percent super moderated
campaign so facing a rebuke from voters
and watching the red wave form do they
listen to voters and pump the brakes on
biden's trillions or do they swing for
the left field fence knowing they're
going to get pancaked next november
anyway
so the democrats are divided in the
media end in congress
and after making our lives more
expensive more dangerous more divisive
and starting a culture where they can't
win they're about to hear an even louder
roar from the american people next year
this is only the beginning hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else